ich bin es 1
die höchsten Kosten für die
übersichten über eine Sendung
ob in Frankfurt
Angst hast wenn du morgens aus dem Haus
gehe ist das Duo abgesprochen wer ist
von diesem Thema
das ist natürlich nicht sehr Bedauern
würde aber ich werde kommen so der
Jurist
er schien ein gutes zu kommen müsste
wegen einer
dann lohnt es sich ja doch aber ich
Versuche auch ein bisschen außer zu
hören dass ich gleich Normzeiten findet
das ist das auch verstanden Lot
ich habe TMZ Plück bisher noch nie
irgendwie eine eine wirkliche wichtige
Drohungen bekommen «Uns hat mir noch
keiner in die Schnauze hauen oder
ähnliches
am ZOB wurde ich ganz ehrlich bin es gab
zweimal in dem Moment wo ich ihn durch
einen wirklich etwas Angst bekam als es
so
in die Richtung die man verwies im Ziel
rundum Bushido Kay One und sowas Prozent
er parodiert habe weil ich weiß das
sind halt junge Menschen die Dirk anders
als die Flippers
die auf andere als gefährlich sind um
die BaFin sind Haiti auf die jungen um
Hallo stehen unter drogen- und sind auch
wie soll ich mal latent gewaltbereit
muss höflich auszudrücken
und manchmal auch bewaffnet Mai Prozent
ich war einmal im
im Hotel unter anderem auch ein paar
Leute von der Reeperbahn die und wenig
Wehking unterkam der Kenner und besagte
besonders bisher nicht in Sätzen
Befragten Roms haben
die Herren erhöhte sind ungehalten und
bewaffnet
das Finance verändert
ungehalten und bewaffnet
am Hund genau deswegen hätten Vorfahrt
vor einigen der schon Angst aber Gott
sei dank zum Glück hat noch kein
Volksmusiker und auch noch kein anderer
ausgeformt wo ich wohne
und dass deswegen konnte mir bisher noch
keine auflauern ich hoffe dass ich noch
weiter
Glück haben werde